we're players in infinite games every
day of Our Lives whether we know it or
not like you're not going to win your
marriage right you can't be number one
in your marriage number two for sure but
never number one
um uh nobody wins education you can come
in first for the finite amount of time
you're at school where we agreed upon
the time frame and we agreed upon the
metrics called grades but nobody wins
education nobody wins health care nobody
wins career and definitely no company is
declared the winner of business right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't know the game they're
playing in they talk about being number
one being the best or beating their
competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon metrics objectives or time frames
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when you play to win in a
game that has no Finish Line
they're a predictable and consistent
outcomes the big ones being the decline
of trust the decline of cooperation and
the decline of innovation like when
Circuit City went bankrupt Best Buy
didn't win anything right all that
happened is they lost one of the players
other players fill the Gap and they have
to learn to reinvent because now
Amazon's a new competitor and now they
have to completely change the way they
want to play otherwise they'll fall out
of the game as well
um and so this was profound for me
because when I started to apply that
definition to my work and the business
World it became abundantly clear that
starting in the late 70s early 80s our
nation was the way we we distorted
capitalism like Adam Smith capitalism
that made this country great and made it
what as wealthy as it is and gave it
such remarkable influence and we're the
most Innovative Innovative nation in the
world almost almost every great
invention that has affected the planet
Earth came from us right
um which is astonishing modern modern
inventions clearly mathematics wasn't
ours but you start to see the
dismantling
of that infinite mindset that Adam Smith
and Thomas Jefferson and all these folks
embraced
uh Thomas Jefferson was a huge fan of
Adam Smith
um and you start to see this more
finite-mindedness the rise of
shareholder Supremacy
where an ex a disinterested external
constituency becomes more important than
a customer an employee which is like a
coach of a team trying to make a great
team by taking advice from fair
weathered fans and ignoring the needs of
players I mean that's kind of what that
is
um you see the rise of things like using
mass layoffs on a regular basis to
balance the books we were profitable
just not as profitable as we had
promised so all of you lose your job oh
no you've been great it's not a
meritocracy you know and you start to
see the steady drumbeat over the course
of the past 30 40 years where we have
actually been dismantling
the awesomeness of American capitals I'm
a die hard capitalist just not the form
that we've we've we've created and it's
very very recent it's very very modern
and Jack Welch is the poster child for
that form of capitalism you know Gordon
Gekko but he's a fictional character
um uh and and we've seen the result
which we've seen massive backlash we've
seen the decline in the life of a
lifespan of companies right it went from
60 years to now which is 17 years the
average lifespan of a company
um we've seen declines in Innovation
we've seen disengagement from employees
we've seen lack of loyalty from
employees we you know we complain about
young people that you know they're not
loyal and they Bounce from job well
think how they grow up they watch their
parents get laid off through no fault of
their own because of this insane system
um so why should they be loyal I don't
blame them
um and we see we see uh the results we
see increases in stress and
disengagement and malaise and depression
and anxiety these are all relate the
great resignation which if we want to go
down that rabbit hole all related
so um I think there's a massive
opportunity for forward-thinking
companies because GE and and those
companies had massive influence in the
direction of
capitalism because they were so wealthy
others just copied them right not
because they were good but because they
had short-term success other but others
went it's working for them and because
the whole system's an upheaval
there's massive opportunity for for
newcom for a new company there is no
error apparent
to redirect what the future of American
Business will look like